[Musique]
bonjour parole de candidat avec et dry
en rangoly qui se présente dans la
circonscription du centre bonjour
bonjour pourquoi vous présentez vous aux
élections législatives 2022 et brian
rangoly et bien écoutez ça fait des
années que moi en tant que jeune je
considère qu'il n'y a pas
d'accompagnement nécessaires pour que
mon pays pour que mon avenir soit un
avenir meilleur que ce que ce qu'on nous
propose à l'heure actuelle donc j'ai
décidé de par mon envie de changer mon
envie de d'améliorer les conditions de
vie des martiniquais de me lancer à la
course aux élections législatives et
pourquoi avec reconquête eric zemmour
alors écoutez c'est très simple à la
première raison parce que
lorsqu'il a créé reconquête c'était pour
rassembler la droite tout je suis de
droite comme je l ai toujours été et
deuxièmement lorsqu'il dit qu'il veut
redonner la france aux français ben moi
je cours de la matinée commence et
necker avant tout voilà voilà alors
quels sont les deux ou trois ans un
projet si vous avez le temps de répit 3
quels sont les deux ou trois projets ou
idées prioritaires pour la martinique
que vous comptez défendre si vous êtes
élu et que donc vous vous retrouvez à
pouvoir vous exprimer à l'assemblée
nationale alors premièrement
je ne vais pas dire que je vais faire
dix mille propositions de loi c où on le
sait très bien que les députés en tout
cas ultra marins ne sont peu ou pas
entendus lorsqu'ils font des
propositions de loi mais ce que je peux
dire ce que toutes les voix qui sont
propices au bon développement économique
ou social démenti ni cas du père
martiniquais mais je serai là pour vous
les faire appliquer puisque nous avons
de nombreuses lois qui ne sont pas
applicables ou qu'ils méritent a modifié
et nous ferons le nécessaire par exemple
ce sera par rapport aussi que ce soit
par rapport à nos jeunes qui quittent le
territoire il faut trouver une solution
nécessaire pour ça parce que vous on le
sait très bien a mentionné car en terme
de population est en pertes de naissance
et il faut faire le nécessaire pour
pouvoir retrouver notre stabilité en
tant qu'humain entre pouvoir préserver
notre culture patrimoine et tout ce qui
va avec
donc c'est ça c'est la protection de la
vie humaine et martiniquais pour
miremont deuxièmement la protection des
économies martiniquaise d'accord faire
en sorte qu'une économie sécurité
sociale faire en sorte qu'ils aient
martin que
fonctionne - son importation mais plus
en consommation locale c'est une de nos
priorités et troisièmement d'avoir le
nécessaire pour leur retraite c'est une
grande question que beaucoup de nos
candidats ne parle pas mais c'est la
question de la retraite quel âge et
quels sont les fonds nécessaire que
l'état va mettre en place pour les
martiniquais lorsqu'ils partiront à la
retraite alors concernant la situation
et les difficultés rencontrées dans
votre circonscription
donc la première celle du centre
atlantique
dans laquelle vous présenter et de ryan
rangoly qu'elle serait là encore vos
deux ou trois priorités en tant que
députés élus dans cette circonscription
à l'or il faut savoir que sur la
première circonscription m'ont remis à
lille et à 5 communes mais en prirent
ainsi qu aux vins de bordeaux mais en
priorité c'est le gros manque donc c'est
une gomme et qu'un clavier c'est une
commune qui manquent d'économies qui
manque de développement
socio- son territoire et il faudra
apporter de nécessaire donc en priorité
ce serait d'agir au pot la commune du
robert du grand pardon pour le robert
alors là les complexités qu'ils ont
c'est soit c'est par rapport aux déchets
de retrouver le pas trouvé mais mettre
en place les nénés réglementation
nécessaire boc à la population soit
protégé par rapport à ces déchets
d'accord puisque vous savez très bien
que ça fait des années et des années qui
a des problématiques les déchets se se
mélangent aux champs agricoles et il
faut il faut mettre très mal à cela et
troisièmement pour le lamantin bon le la
montée c'est plus au niveau du beausset
centre ville qui mériterait que ce soit
la montée ou au mans nous font ou la
france aux autres et mériterait d'être
accompagné développé pour que les
premiers soit aux martiniquais
et dryden rangoly je vous reste une
minute pour vous adresser directement
donc aux électrices et électeurs de la
circonscription du centre atlantique
alors ça va être très simple les choux
martinique et martiniquaise voilà plus
de 60 70 ans que notre martinique est
sous l'eau ça fait plus de 60 70 ans que
les mêmes politiciens nous disent que
nous sommes aux problématiques et nous
manque de l'argent il ne cesse de
demander à la france des finances
lorsque nous savons très bien que si
nous travaillons si nous collaborons si
nous fonctionnons ensemble nous pouvons
faire en sorte qu'elle a menti nigré
puis ça avance rayonnement que nous
devions avoir depuis des années nous ne
serons ni les pompiers ni les
marionnettes de l'état français nous
sommes traités d'égal à égal en élisant
députés comme moi même donc rango les
dren dès le premier tour voter
organiserait merci adrian rangoly
d'avoir et merci à vous allez vite à ces
questions